that eight billion dollar ramp line
isn't going to do anything to the ramp
companies or ramp prices and you're
going to be the true victim of the fire
because you are going to be the one who
is going to pay for it
[Music]
welcome to Horace Holidays so last year
China's anti-monopoly a Bureau of
Ministry of Commerce visited SK Hynix
Samsung and micron to point out their
concerns over their really high ramp
prices but as you guys already know that
didn't lead to anything in ramp prices
really just increase over the past year
as a result China's antitrust regulators
launched a full investigation into
whether or not
Samsung SK Hynix and micron have been
price-fixing and if they are found
guilty they will have to pay fines
ranging from eight hundred million
dollars to eight billion dollars which
are calculated based on the DRAM sales
in China between 2016 and 2017
now that sounds good at all but here's
why it's not really going to do anything
except potentially harmless first of all
these companies have already priced
fixed in the past and have been fined
for it for example in 2004 SK Hynix paid
185 million dollars in fines and Samsung
paid 300 million so if there are
price-fixing again obviously these fines
aren't enough to deter them from doing
so I know is that fine is a lot higher
than last time but so are the sales and
profit for samsung s cojones and micron
therefore that fines proportionate to
the sales and if they're still repeating
that crime it is obviously still
profitable and as a result this fine is
probably not going to stop them and the
next thing is considering that they have
already gotten busted once they have
probably learned from how they got
busted and they probably have covered up
their tracks this time and even if they
didn't fully cover up their tracks
I really doubt the fine is going to be
the maximum of eight billion dollars
plus that final will be split between
the three companies so that makes a
payment even less it's not like one
company
paying eight billion dollars so even if
the finest eight billion dollars which
it most likely won't be each company
won't pay nearly that amount but you may
be thinking two to three billion dollars
is still a lot of money and even if it's
not a game changer it will definitely
put it down all the companies and act as
a deterrent to not price fix again and
that may be true but when you really
think about it what does this find even
accomplish in the first place first the
Chinese government is getting all of
this money and second no one who
overpaid for Ram is getting any money
back so really the consumers aren't
benefiting at all and really the Chinese
government is the only people who could
benefit from this fine to make matters
even worse when you really think about
it is going to be us who are paying for
this fine in the first place whether
it's more months of these high ramp
prices or its ramp prices going up even
more to accommodate for its expenses in
the end is going to be us who are
indirectly paying for it so not only is
the punishment not returning money to
consumers who were paid for in the first
place but it will also make us pay for
the fine so based on all that when will
RAM prices finally go down well
unfortunately RAM prices aren't moving
anywhere unless it's going up until at
least 2019 so it's really quite a while
from now and with this new potential
find and the new iPhones releasing soon
RAM prices are really just bound to go
up to make matters even worse many
manufacturers of RAM are currently in
the process of changing their process
from for example 60 nanometers to 12
nanometers and as a result they can't
really increase production right now
thus the future of RAM prices don't look
very bright and this new fine could
really just make things worse
so when should you buy a ramp well in my
opinion if you really need RAM the best
time to buy RAM is probably right now
because Ram prices are probably not
going down for quite a while and they're
probably just go up so you may just end
up paying more for them if you
wait so overall there was a lot of hype
surrounding the Chinese government
taking action and pressing charges
against these Ram companies for eight
billion dollars but in reality it is not
as great as the hype made it sound
because first of all they may not even
be found guilty and even if they're
charged it will most likely not be eight
billion dollars and Plus is being split
by the three companies anyways and even
if there are charges of fine the people
who overpaid for the RAM are not going
to benefit from it and plus we are
probably going to have to pay for the
fine indirectly the end goal of the fine
is really to make the RAM pricing
situation better but in my opinion I
think it may just make it worse but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think this Ram
client is going to make the pricing
situation better or worse make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like severe that make sure to
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one but until next time bye
[Music]